- I want to welcome you all
to the 2023 Castle Lectures,
which are the signature
lectures for the EP&E program.
We had a long pause because of COVID,
but we're very pleased to
finally be able to be back here
organizing these events in person.
My name is Ana de la O,
and I am the Director of the EP&E program.
And before introducing our
speaker today, Ben Wizner,
I want to tell you just a little bit
about these Castle Lectures.
In 1988, John Castle made
a generous gift to Yale
to establish the lecture series.
He did so in honor of his
ancestor, Reverend James Pierpont.
He was a Harvard trained
Congregationalist minister
who founded the Collegiate
School of Connecticut in 1701.
Soon after, that School
of Connecticut was renamed
after its benefactor, Elihu Yale.
We are grateful to Mr.
Castle and his family
to the contribution to
the university, broadly,
and to the EP&E program, in particular.
The Castle Lectures aim
to promote awareness
of the ethical challenges and
complexities of our society.
And they're also meant
to foster robust dialogue
about the moral foundations
of society and government.
Our speaker today is Ben Wizner.
He's the director of the
American Civil Liberties Union's
Speech, Privacy, and Technology Project.
In more than two decades at the ACLU,
Ben has litigated many significant cases
at the intersection of human
rights and national security,
including challenges to
the surveillance practices,
government security, sorry,
government watch lists,
targeted killings, and torture.
Since 2013, he has been
the principal legal advisor
to NSA whistleblower Edward Snowden.
Ben is a graduate of Harvard College
and New York University School of Law.
His lecture series are entitled
"Above the Law, or Beneath It,
How National Security Law
Subverts Accountability
and Weakens Democracy."
These lecture series are going
to be divided in two parts.
So this is a two day event.
Today's lecture, has a title
"Anatomy of a National Security Lawsuit."
Tomorrow we're gonna meet again
at the same time, 4:00 PM,
to hear the second part of the lecture,
which is entitled "The Case
Against 'National Security'."
Just a few words about the
format of these lectures.
We're gonna let Ben present
for about 45, 50 minutes
and then we're going to have
plenty of time for questions.
So I'm going to ask you to
please hold your questions
towards the end, even though I know
this is going to be a terrific
and thought-provoking (chuckles) lecture.
So please, welcome me in joining Ben.
And Ben, the floor is yours.
- [Ben] Thank you. Thanks.
(audience applauding)
Thank you for that introduction, Ana,
and thank you all for
being here this afternoon.
I'm honored to be invited
to offer these lectures
in what is my hometown.
One of the privileges of growing up
in a community like this
one is that you have access
to a world of expertise
outside your own family.
When I was a 17 year
old, high school senior,
nervous, a little
headstrong about heading off
to Harvard in the fall,
I asked the political
theorist, Ian Shapiro,
whether I should take the year long
Introduction to Economics, Ec 10,
which at that time was taught
by the renowned conservative
economist Martin Feldstein.
"You could," he responded,
and I will not attempt
a South African accent,
(audience chuckling)
"or I could teach it to
you in one sentence."
(audience laughing)
This was thrilling to hear.
"What's the sentence?" I asked.
His response, "Imagine the world is flat."
At the time, this sounded
like a cryptic koan.
Only later did I appreciate
it as a glib dismissal
of the premise that human
behavior is best understood
as a series of rational
cost-benefit analyses.
It's genuinely hard for me
to fathom that I am older now
than Ian Shapiro was at
the time of that exchange.
And that Harvard's canonical
Ec 10 is now taught
by one of my college drinking buddies.
(audience laughing)
No less boggling is that it
now falls to me and my cohort
to play Zen master and to
perplex and enlighten the youth.
So here it goes.
If a bright and idealistic
college graduate
on her way to law school
were to ask me today
whether she should take a
course in national security law,
I would be tempted to channel Ian Shapiro
and offer to teach it to
her in a single sentence.
Something like, "The time
bomb is always ticking."
Or maybe, "We neither confirm nor deny
what you see in plain sight."
Or better still, "Heads, we win.
Tails, you lose."
National security law has
not achieved the status
in law schools that
macroeconomics occupies
in our colleges and universities,
but it's on the march.
In the two decades since the 9/11 attacks,
it's moved from the fringes
of law school curricula
to a privileged front and center position.
New courses have proliferated.
New journals have launched.
Leading law schools have
announced prestigious fellowships,
think tank collaborations,
and all manner of grace
that the academy can bestow.
As a lawyer who spent the better part
of the last two decades litigating,
or rather attempting to litigate,
national security law cases,
I've observed these developments
with a mix of bewilderment and annoyance.
To be sure, many of the
questions and controversies
that fall within the rubric
of national security law
are vital ones that deserve significant
attention and careful scrutiny.
But when confronted with those
questions in recent years,
courts in the United States
have almost uniformly refused
to grapple with them.
Instead, deeming them non-justiciable.
Did military officials
violate the constitution
when they seized a U.S.
citizen on U.S. soil,
held him for years, incommunicado
in solitary confinement,
and subjected him to beatings,
sensory deprivation, and forced drugging?
We don't know,
because federal courts in South Carolina
and Virginia decline
to answer on the ground
that Congress had not created
a specific cause of action
for alleged enemy combatants
claiming abuse in military custody.
Are there any legal constraints
on the government's authority
to carry out targeted killings
of U.S. citizen terrorism suspects
far from any recognizable battlefield?
Put otherwise, can the
government carry out
the extrajudicial killing
of one of its own citizens
without even telling him
what conduct might
subject him to execution?
We don't know, because the federal court
in the District of Columbia
dismissed a lawsuit
on the ground that it falls
to the political branches
rather than the judiciary to decide
whether and when U.S. citizens
may be killed overseas.
Does a federal law that
authorizes the mass acquisition
of U.S. Citizens' international telephone
and email communications
without individualized judicial warrants
violate the Constitution's
Fourth Amendment?
We don't know, because the
U.S. Supreme Court said
that the plaintiffs who brought
the challenge could not show
that their own communications
had been swept up,
and they, therefore, lack
standing to bring a lawsuit.
Can a foreign citizen who
was kidnapped by the CIA
in a case of mistaken identity,
and imprisoned and abused
in a foreign dungeon claim
any remedy under U.S. law?
We don't know, because courts
in Virginia accepted the CIA's
argument that any litigation
of the claims would reveal state secrets
and damage national security.
And just last month,
can the National Security
Agency intercept and copy all
of Americans' international
communications including emails,
web browsing content,
search engine queries
by installing surveillance devices
on the Internet's backbone and then search
that massive database
without any court approval?
We don't know, because in February,
the Supreme Court refused to
review a lower court ruling,
dismissing that case on secrecy grounds.
Warrantless surveillance
of American citizens,
kidnapping and torture at home and abroad,
extrajudicial kill lists.
Non-justiciable,
non-justiciable, non-justiciable.
These outcomes deprive
litigants of remedies,
but of greater significance,
by failing to say what the law is,
they deprive the nation of
a definitive adjudication,
allow abuses to continue unchecked,
and leave the door open
for future misconduct.
Even in those rare instances
in which courts have rejected
these most extreme outcomes,
most notably, when the
Supreme Court repudiated
the Bush administration's crude attempt
to overrule the Magna Carta in Guantanamo,
the court's rulings have often been
more symbol than substance,
a court claiming authority
rather than exercising it.
The government may have lost
three landmark Guantanamo cases,
but more than 20 years
into the Guantanamo era,
the Supreme Court still has not told us
whether indefinite detention
without trial there is lawful.
All of this litigation, without
any substantive outcomes,
generates a kind of fog
of law that conceals
what I believe to be the
real organizing principle
of national security law,
impunity for senior officials.
This regime is robust and
malleable and has proven adept
across decades at identifying new hosts.
It will not be dislodged anytime soon.
The more modest goal of this
polemic is to contribute
to a process of diminishing
its respectability.
It makes perfect sense that
the high priests of this order,
those senior officials who
float between top positions
in the intelligence community
and defense contracting,
would seek to imbue their project
with the gravity and solemnity
of an existential struggle
and would view challenges
to their noble efforts
as attempts to tie their hands
during what they insist
on defining as wartime.
There's no good reason
why the rest of society,
least of all the academy, should
consent to that definition
or participate in that mythmaking.
The intelligence community
uses the term "indoctrination"
to describe the process of being
sworn into the secret world
of security clearance.
National security law, likewise,
seeks to indoctrinate us
into a profoundly anti-democratic way
of thinking about governance.
National security law is organized
around the systematic
exclusion of the public
from vital decisions
about government policy.
It insists that the separate
branches of government
that were designed to provide
a check on executive abuses
must instead defer to
the purported expertise
of the executive wrongdoers themselves.
Indeed, national security
law is predicated
on democratic fragility.
Insofar as, its central claim
that we need an exceptional set of rules
to address putatively exceptional threats,
invariably implies, in
Wendell Berry's words that,
"A democracy such as ours can work only
in the most favorable circumstances."
It's more than a little ironic
that a rogues' gallery of
national security elites
has pulled off a nifty recent rebrand
by embracing the banner of democracy
after devoting their careers
to weakening its checks and balances.
In tomorrow's lecture,
I'll dig a little deeper
into why I believe national security law
is, at best, incoherent,
and at worse, a carefully
cultivated deception.
Today, I want to take you on a journey
deep down the rabbit hole
of one relatively obscure
national security case.
But before I do that,
I hope you'll indulge a brief
Admiral Stockdale moment,
"Who am I? What am I doing here?"
This is is my test to see who
in the room is 50 or older.
Very few. (chuckling)
(audience laughing)
As is probably clear by now,
I don't quite fit the profile
of past lecturers in this series.
I've not spent my career
reading and writing
about the issues that
I'm here to talk about.
But rather, being battered around by them
in a hostile arena.
This was not by design.
I didn't set out to be a
national security lawyer.
Mine was the last generation
to graduate law school
before the 9/11 attacks, and thus,
before our national security
law became enshrined
as a prominent fixture.
Our graduation week class gala,
our so-called Last Chance Dance,
took place at Windows on the World,
atop of the World Trade Center
on an exceptionally foggy
night in May of 2000.
Among the many things we
couldn't see that night
was how our lives and
careers would be shaped
by the unthinkable events
that would unfold there a year later.
I've often thought about
the cooks, waiters,
and cleaners who served
us and whether any of them
might have died in that
room one year later.
In August of 2001, a month before the day
that ended the end of history,
I joined the ACLU as a staff attorney.
Lionel Trilling said of
the Spanish Civil War,
"Everyone knew that it was one
of the decisive events of our epic.
Everyone said so at the
time it was being fought,
and everyone was right."
This fairly well captures
the sense of dread
and anticipation that we all experienced
in September of 2001.
Even before wars of choice were launched,
prisoners were brutalized,
and our national discourse
devolved into the conceptual
and moral absurdity of a war on terror.
The two decades of my ACLU career
have tracked the two
decades of this forever war
from Washington, D.C. courtrooms
to Guantanamo Bay, Cuba,
to the ancient capital of Yemen,
and most unexpectedly, to Moscow.
But much of that time has
been spent at my desk,
reading and writing legal briefs,
trying without success to
persuade courts to rule
on the legality of
executive actions undertaken
in the name of national security.
There are national security lawsuits
that produce lofty judicial pronouncements
and fill law school casebooks.
There are others that make headlines,
even if they don't make law.
The case I'm going to talk
about today is none of those.
It certainly is not among
the more important cases
that I lost.
I've chosen it because I think
it epitomizes the pathologies
of national security
litigation and offers a flavor
of the style of argument
that the government employs
and courts routinely
accept in these cases.
The lawsuit concerned a request
under the Freedom of Information Act
for a few dozen pages of documents.
In particular, a request to
the Department of Defense
and the Central Intelligence Agency
for unredacted transcripts of a handful
of Combatant Status Review
Tribunal proceedings
at Guantanamo Bay.
If you don't know what
that sentence meant,
I congratulate you.
(audience laughing)
If you do, hello, old friend.
We'll catch up after the lecture.
(audience laughing)
Before I get to the case,
I should set the stage,
and I apologize to those of
you for whom this is remedial.
The particular quasi-legal
proceedings at the center
of this dispute represent the convergence
of two of the more disgraceful
policy decisions made
by the Bush administration after 9/11,
the attempt to create a legal
no man's land in Guantanamo
and the creation of an archipelago
of secret CIA run torture
prisons around the world.
The Bush administration
opened the prison camp
in Guantanamo Bay in January, 2002.
The plan of course was
to locate the prison
outside the jurisdiction
of our federal courts
to create an island
outside the law so that men
and boys could be imprisoned
without legal recourse
and interrogated without legal restraint.
The prisoners were prohibited
from contacting lawyers,
and lawyers were prohibited
from visiting the prison.
When human rights lawyers
found a workaround
by locating family
members of the prisoners
and initiating habeas corpus
proceedings in federal courts,
the government insisted
that the suits be dismissed
on jurisdictional grounds
with no adjudication
of whether the prisoners
had been lawfully captured
and detained.
"Would the government's
arguments be the same,"
one federal judge asked
in a hearing in 2003,
"if the claims were that the government
was engaging in acts of torture
or even extrajudicial execution?"
"Yes," said the Department of Justice,
"there would be no jurisdiction
to consider those claims either."
In hindsight, it seems clear
that the government
would've been better off
inviting judicial review
rather than fighting it.
As I mentioned earlier, two decades later
and after a trio of cases
in which the Supreme Court repudiated
the government's efforts to
evade any judicial review,
the court has still not answered
the fundamental question,
whether indefinite military detention
at Guantanamo was or is lawful.
In other words, the court
dramatically clawed back a power
that it has steadfastly
declined to exercise,
demonstrating a greater willingness
to defend its own prerogatives
than to interfere with executive abuses.
In 2004, in the first
of those three cases,
the Supreme Court in Rasul v. Bush held
that because the United States
exercised complete sovereign control
over the Guantanamo Naval base,
the prisoners there could
file habeas corpus petitions
in U.S. federal courts.
About a month after the Rasul decision,
the Department of Defense established
the Combatant Status Review Tribunals,
or CSRTs, as they are
more commonly called.
These were ad hoc administrative bodies
charged with determining
whether the prisoners had
been properly classified
as enemy combatants.
Depending on your perspective,
CSRTs were either quote,
"The most generous set
of procedural protections
ever afforded aliens
detained by this country
as enemy combatants,"
as Chief Justice Roberts
would later write,
or a Potemkin proceeding designed
to offer an illusion of legal process
and thereby stave off
full-blown intervention
by federal courts.
The CSRTs were composed of a panel
of three military officers and an officer
known as the recorder who served
in the prosecutorial role.
The prisoners had no legal representation.
The tribunal could rely
on secret evidence,
and invariably did,
and on evidence obtained
through coercive interrogation.
If the CSRT determined
that the prisoner was properly classified
as an enemy combatant,
which was the outcome in all but 38
of the 558 hearings conducted
between July of 2004 and March of 2005,
that prisoner could be held
at Guantanamo indefinitely,
subject only to an annual review
before an administrative review board.
Meanwhile, even as the Department
of Defense was insisting
that Guantanamo held
the worst of the worst,
hardened terrorists who would,
in the words of the nation's
top uniform military officer
"chew through a hydraulics
cable to bring a plane down",
the Bush administration had
set up a separate detention
and interrogation regime for
a smaller number of prisoners
whom the CIA deemed high
value detainees, or HVDs.
These were the so-called black sites,
the aptly named dungeons,
where the U.S. committed the gravest
of all human rights abuses,
forced disappearance,
incommunicado detention,
brutal torture, even homicide.
It was in these prisons
that CIA interrogators
employ the techniques
that were purportedly authorized
by the notorious Department
of Justice "torture memos",
including slamming prisoners into walls,
depriving them of sleep
for prolonged periods,
chaining them in stress positions,
placing them in a
confinement box with insects,
and waterboarding.
In September of 2006,
the CIA's remaining high
value detainees were upgraded
from secret CIA detention to
indefinite military detention
and transferred from
black sites to Guantanamo.
Shortly after their transfer,
the 14 former CIA prisoners
went through the CSRT process
and transcripts of those
hearings were released.
Those transcripts were incomplete.
Virtually all references to
the prisoners' interrogation
and conditions of
confinement had been scrubbed
from the released versions.
For example, during the
March 14th, 2006 CSRT hearing
for Abd al-Rahim al-Nashiri,
Mr. Nashiri stated that he had
been tortured in CIA custody.
When a tribunal member asked him
to describe the methods
that had been used,
the released transcript
recorded the following,
"Redacted, what else do I want to say?
Redacted. They were doing so many things.
What else did they did? Redacted.
After that, another method
of torture began. Redacted.
They used to ask me questions
and the investigator
after that used to laugh.
And I used to answer
the answer that I knew.
And if I didn't replay what I
heard, he used to, redacted."
All of that has been scene
setting for tonight's main event,
American Civil Liberties Union
versus Department of Defense
and Central Intelligence Agency,
the ACLU submitted a Freedom
of Information Act request
on April 20, 2007, seeking complete
and unredacted records of
these CSRT proceedings,
and we followed that request
with a lawsuit to enforce it.
We knew better than to be optimistic,
but it seemed to us that
the government's basis
for classifying these transcripts
was exceptionally weak.
It would get even weaker as
the litigation progressed.
First, we weren't asking for
official government records
describing the torture program.
We simply wanted transcripts
that recorded the prisoners'
experiences in their own words.
Unlike the notorious "torture memos",
the legal opinions drafted
by the Department of Justice's
Office of Legal Counsel
that purported to authorize
the brutal techniques
these prisoners were subjected to,
these transcripts didn't constitute
official government policy.
On the contrary,
they were the abbreviated
firsthand accounts
of some of our most reviled adversaries,
accounts that were,
therefore, easily dismissible
and had, in fact, been routinely dismissed
as lies by senior officials.
Second, by the time this
lawsuit reached the courts,
the CIA's torture program was no secret.
Detailed accounts of the CIA's black sites
and the brutality that occurred
there had been published
and widely disseminated.
During the course of the litigation,
and particularly, after
President Obama took office,
many official records of abuse,
including the "torture memos",
were declassified and released.
By any reasonable metric, the
release of these transcripts
should have cost the
government very little.
That was not the CIA's view.
Throughout the litigation,
the CIA insisted
that the redacted portions
of the transcripts
must retain their "Top
Secret" designation,
meaning their release
reasonably could be expected
to cause exceptionally grave
damage to national security
because they included information
about the agency's intelligence,
sources, and methods.
Before we take a deeper dive
into some of the absurdities
of the government's argument,
I want to linger for a
moment on that core claim,
that release of a few dozen
pages of hearing transcripts
in which prisoners
describe their treatment
in CIA custody would endanger the nation.
Those of us who work in this
area have become so inure
to this casual threat
inflation that we rarely paused
to consider what the government
is asking us to believe.
In this case, that the release
of these 40 or so pages
would have any impact
on the security of a global hyperpower,
much less an exceptionally grave one.
Such an assertion should
strike any reasonable observer
as fundamentally odd,
and the government offered
some very odd arguments
in its defense.
The first of those arguments
was that the government had the authority
to classify these transcripts
in the first place.
"By what law or logic," we wondered,
"could the government classify
the prisoner's own words and memories
derive from their own
observations and experiences?"
The government's authority
to detain a prisoner had
never been understood
to encompass the authority to classify any
and all utterances made by that prisoner.
And the legal requirement
that classified national
security information
be owned by, produced by, or for,
or be under the control of
the United States government
had never before been
extended to human beings
under the government's control.
Put even more bluntly, the CIA was arguing
that it can subject an individual
to enhanced interrogation techniques,
and then by virtue of that
individual's involuntary exposure
to those techniques alone,
enforce a permanent gag
on his communication.
In a sworn declaration
submitted to the court,
a CIA Associate Information Officer stated
that the 14 high value detainees included
in plaintiff's request "have been exposed"
to intelligence activities, sources,
and methods of information.
Specifically quoting, "The
intelligence activities
to which the high value
detainees were exposed
include the capture,
detention, confinement,
and interrogation of detainees."
That is, they were exposed,
as it were, to themselves.
What's more, the CIA's ability
to conceal this information
was predicated entirely on the
government's physical custody
of the detainees.
In other words, the argument presumed
that they would not be released.
By this logic, the ACLU argued,
the CIA could mistakenly detain
and coercively interrogate
an entirely innocent person,
something that in fact
happened many times.
But if that person were exposed
to classified interrogation techniques,
permitting him to describe his ordeal
would cause exceptionally grave
harm to national security,
so his release would be impossible.
Of course, if the government were correct
that the detainee's exposure
to classified intelligence,
sources, and methods
justified an indefinite
gag on their communication,
then surely it would follow
that whoever disclosed those methods
to terrorism suspects had
violated criminal statutes,
prohibiting the transmission
of intelligence secrets
to anyone unauthorized to receive them.
That is to say, at the very moment,
that hooded CIA interrogators
were pouring water
down the throat of Khalid Sheikh Mohammed,
they were engaged in an unauthorized leak
of top secret information
to an avowed enemy
of the United States, no less.
That's obviously silly.
The CIA interrogators and their
bosses should be prosecuted
for torture, not leaking.
But is it any sillier than the
government's argument here?
And that was not even the strangest
of the arguments that the government made.
The government had
repeatedly characterized
the detainees' torture
allegations as false.
Secretary of Defense
Rumsfeld, for example,
responded to a question about torture
at Guantanamo with ridicule,
"The detainees were doing exactly
what they were trained to tell people.
'Tell them you're tortured.
Tell them it's terrible.
Tell them this. Tell them that.'
That's what they do."
Even if we were to accept the argument
that the detainees true
accounts of their own detention
and interrogation might
include sensitive details,
how could false accusations
disclose secrets?
How could the government deny
and classify the same allegations?
Easily, as it turns out,
and with no discernible embarrassment.
According to the CIA sworn declaration,
even false allegations
about the classified details
of the program must be treated
as classified information.
The CIA did not purport to explain
how an allegation could
simultaneously be false
and be about the classified
details of the program,
an assertion that defies ordinary logic.
The declaration then
offered a hypothetical.
If the government were to
redact only true allegations
regarding locations of
CIA detention facilities,
then the true locations
of these facilities
could be revealed by
making multiple allegations
as to location through a
simple process of elimination.
That doesn't strike me as very simple.
Was the CIA suggesting that publication
of a detainee's false
assertion that he was detained
in, say, Afghanistan, could
alert a canny observer
that the true location was Morocco
through some kind of
terrorist decoder ring?
Or was the government imagining a scenario
in which an expert
manipulator gamed the system
by falsely naming every nation
in the world except one?
The CIA did not elaborate.
While the ACLU and the government
were trading sharply-worded briefs,
President Obama took office.
And in one of his first executive orders,
he categorically banned the
interrogation techniques
that the CIA insisted were
classified sources and methods
of intelligence gathering.
This should have resolved the litigation.
How could a banned technique,
a technique that the CIA
by law could not use again,
remain a classifiable source and method?
Even assuming that the
torture techniques were
at one point legitimate and lawful methods
of intelligence gathering,
no amount of disclosure
about their past use could reveal details
about current intelligence
sources and methods,
then might be properly
protected by the CIA.
In a new sworn declaration,
the CIA acknowledged
that the interrogation techniques at issue
had been prohibited by law, but it argued,
"Even if the enhanced
interrogation techniques
are never used again,
the United States will
continue to be involved
in questioning terrorists under
legally approved guidelines.
The information in these documents
would provide future
terrorists with a guidebook
on how to evade such questioning."
If you're wondering exactly how knowledge
about banned interrogation techniques
would aid future captives
in resisting new and different
techniques, you're not alone.
The CIA made no effort to explain that.
More disorienting, was
that the CIA continued
to press arguments in court
that directly contradicted
what the President, their
putative boss, had said in public.
President Obama had repudiated
the CIA's brutal interrogation techniques,
and stated that they
did not advance our war
and counter-terrorism efforts.
They undermine them.
But the government continued
to argue in our litigation
that those techniques had quote,
"Provided the U.S. government
with one of the most useful tools
in combating terrorist
threats to national security."
The CIA told the court
that the now banned techniques had quote,
"Led to the disruption
of a plot to fly a plane
into the tallest building in Los Angeles
and a plot to hijack passenger planes
to fly into Heathrow Airport,"
even though those claims
had been repeatedly debunked
and were provably false.
The Bush White House
had, itself, confirmed
that the Los Angeles plot was disrupted
before the CIA's detention
and interrogation program even began,
and the British government
dismissed the CIA's claim
about the Heathrow plot as
completely and utterly wrong.
In a 2010 op-ed, Boris Johnson wrote that,
"The CIA's torture of
prisoners had yielded
no information of value to the British,"
and that, "if former President
Bush traveled to the U.K.,
he might fight face arrest for the crime
of waterboarding prisoners and
would never see Texas again."
To my knowledge, President Bush
and Vice President Cheney
have gone nowhere near Europe
since leaving office.
There was yet another dispositive reason
why withholding these transcripts
was legally impermissible.
By the time the courts
were considering the case,
the government had
declassified numerous documents
that formally acknowledged
and described in detail
the interrogation
techniques and conditions
of confinement at issue in the litigation.
I've already mentioned the
notorious "torture memos",
which President Obama
declassified in April of 2009.
These contained concrete and
startling operational details,
including the angle of the gurney
and the temperature of the
water used in waterboarding,
the protocols for stress
positions and sleep deprivation,
and the appalling admission
that one prisoner had
been deprived of sleep
for 180 hours, more than a week.
A few months later,
the Obama administration also
declassified large portions
of a CIA Inspector
General report from 2004.
That report described multiple instances
in which CIA interrogators exceeded
the authority purportedly
granted by the "torture memos",
including incidents in which
al-Nashiri was threatened
with a semi-automatic
handgun and a power drill,
and Khalid Sheikh Mohammed
was warned by interrogators
that his children would be killed
if there were another
terrorist attack in the U.S.
In contrast to the transcripts
at issue in our litigation,
which simply recorded the
detainee's accounts of torture,
these were official government records.
This presented a new twist.
The government had, for
decades, argued successfully
that publication of mere allegations
about classified activities
could not compel the disclosure
of official government documents.
Here, apparently for the first time,
it argued that publication of
official government documents
about classified activities
could not compel the disclosure
of mere allegations.
Heads, we win. Tails, you lose.
So to review, the transcripts
contain descriptions
of the detainee's own experiences,
not any official government account.
The details of their interrogations
had been declassified
and made public in numerous ways.
The President had banned the techniques
that were being withheld as
classified sources and methods.
And despite all of that,
the CIA still swore
and the Department of Justice still argued
that the release of these transcripts
would cause exceptionally grave damage
to the security of the United States.
By this point, I doubt
anyone is in suspense
about what happened next.
The federal district
court in Washington, D.C.
had little difficulty
sweeping our arguments aside
in a cursory order.
It upheld the government's
suppression of the transcripts
without even conducting
in-camera review to examine them.
In other words, it deemed the
CIA's affidavits so credible
that it declined even to
look at the transcripts
before awarding summary
judgment to the government.
We appealed and the court of appeals
for the District of Columbia
Circuit held oral arguments
in September of 2010.
The appellate panel
included conservative icons
Laurence Silberman and David Sentelle,
who made no effort to hide
their disdain for the lawsuit.
They began by asking me
why the ACLU even wanted the transcripts.
If the interrogation details
had been released elsewhere,
what was the point of our request?"
As Judge Silberman put it,
"The argument is not very
convincing that says,
'They should let us have this
because we already have it.'
If we have a non-sequitur contest,
you get to enter that one."
I responded that, "Under the
binding law of their circuit,
the ACLU would be
entitled to the documents
only if the information the CIA claimed
as sources and methods had
been released elsewhere.
So any non-sequitur resulted
from their precedence,
not my illogic."
"In any event," I argued,
"under the FOIA, it was not my burden
to explain why I wanted the documents.
It was the government's burden
to justify their withholding."
"Wait a minute," said Justice Silberman.
"If this information is
already in the public record,
how do you even have standing
to sue for it under the FOIA?
How is there even a case or controversy?"
This was another new one,
and really the definition of a catch-22.
To overcome the government's
claimed exemptions,
we were required to argue
that virtually identical information
had already been disclosed.
But if we argue that virtually
identical information
had already been disclosed,
we would have no standing to sue.
Heads, we win. Tails, you lose.
Judge Silberman's next line of questioning
threw me for a loop,
"Did you ever see the movie
'Saving Private Ryan'?"
he asked me.
(audience chuckling)
"I've seen it, your honor."
"Do you remember the scene on Omaha Beach
when German soldiers were
trying to surrender to GIs,
but they were shot?"
I remembered the scene.
"If there had been a FOIA at that time,
and the shootings had been recorded,
and someone had requested the videos,
would the government have had
to release them in wartime?"
And here, you have to
admire the casual equation
of wartime Normandy in the spring of 1944
with wartime Washington
and that fraught and
perilous autumn of 2010.
I responded, "It's our view
that the government cannot use a crime
as the basis for a coverup.
A contrary rule would create
a perverse incentive,"
I argued.
"The worse the government's conduct,
the more exempt it would
be from disclosure.
This was the opposite of
what Congress intended
when it enacted the FOIA."
I'm cherry picking some of my better lines
in this retelling, but I
should acknowledge here
that the court somewhat
sadistically posts audio recordings
of oral arguments on its website.
And the recording of this one
paints a different picture.
The judges are relaxed, almost bored,
enjoying some occasional
sport at my expense.
I'm testy and can't hide my annoyance.
We all know how it's gonna end.
In an opinion issued on January 18, 2011,
the court unanimously
affirmed summary judgment
for the government on the
basis of the CIA's insistence
that release of the unredacted transcripts
would damage the security
of the United States.
It did so, as had the district court,
without even taking a
few minutes to glance
at the disputed documents
to see if the CIA was lying about them.
I've spent more time than I
should have on this particular,
and ultimately, minor case
because I think it's possible
to distill from it the core tenets
of national security law and practice.
The government wins.
Almost nonsensical arguments
that would insult the intelligence
of a junior high school debater,
"You are prohibited from
speaking about these things
that never happened," are
put forth in somber tones.
The government demands that
judges defer to the expertise
of the very officials who stand
accused of grave misconduct.
That demand is accompanied by
wildly inflated claims of harm
that will result if the court
were, instead, to do its job.
And finally, the ostensible
subject of the dispute,
in this case, transparency versus secrecy,
is a contrived proxy for
what's actually at stake,
accountability versus impunity.
It should be obvious that the
CIA's concern was not harm
to the nation, but harm to the CIA.
The audience they had in
mind was not terrorists
who might learn to evade their
interrogation techniques,
but the American people who
might be appalled by them.
The lesson of Abu Ghraib was fresh.
Images of torture could produce
a dramatically different public reaction
than written descriptions.
This explains the decision
of senior CIA leaders
to destroy video evidence
of torture in black sites.
The agency was willing to
risk potential liability
for obstruction of justice
to avoid the more probable
fallout that would occur
if the horrific videos
were seen and disseminated.
Might the public react strongly
to the emotional firsthand accounts
of human suffering contained
in these redacted transcripts?
The CIA didn't want to take the chance,
and it didn't have to.
We would later learn a
more significant reason
for this suppression of the transcripts.
They contained compelling evidence
that the CIA's torture
regime had been ineffective.
And of course, this was precisely
why we wanted these documents.
President Obama had banned
torture by executive order,
but there was nothing to
bind a future president
intent on reinstating it.
Meanwhile, all of our lawsuits
on behalf of torture
victims had been dismissed
on justiciability grounds
with no ruling on the
legality of the practices.
And while President
Obama had disappointed us
with his insistence that a
nation could look forward
without looking backwards,
we clung to the hope
that we could generate
enough public backlash
to reinvigorate demands
for accountability.
At a minimum,
we hoped to assemble a
comprehensive public record
that might be of value to investigators
in another place or time.
I made the claim a minute ago
that in national security litigation,
disputes over secrecy operate as a proxy
for disputes over accountability.
I want to illustrate more
directly what I mean by that.
Simply put, in 2023 as we stand here,
very little is secret about
the CIA's torture program.
But as a consequence of
legal secrecy doctrines,
every single lawsuit filed by
a torture victim since 9/11
has ended without any
adjudication of the law or facts.
In layman's terms,
no court that was faced
with a torture lawsuit
ever addressed the core question
of whether the victim's
rights were violated.
This includes the case of Khalid El-Masri,
maybe the most well-known victim
of the CIA's so-called
extraordinary rendition program.
In a notorious case of mistaken identity,
El-Masri, a German citizen,
was abducted by Macedonian
security officers
while visiting that country,
detained incommunicado for weeks,
handed over to a CIA renditions team,
then stripped, beaten,
drugged via anal suppository,
diapered, chained to the floor of a plane,
and transported to a secret
CIA prison in Afghanistan
where he was detained
in abusive conditions
for several months.
Senior U.S. officials
realized very quickly
that they had kidnapped
an innocent person.
Because he was a European citizen,
he couldn't be dropped in
Guantanamo to be sorted out later.
So the CIA worked with German
intelligence to devise a plan
that would return him to Germany
without leaving obvious U.S. fingerprints.
El-Masri was warned not
to reveal his experiences
to the media or to local German officials.
Then he was flown to Albania,
driven blindfolded to a remote location,
and left on the side of the road,
whereby prearrangement, he was picked up
by Albanian officers
and put on a plane home.
This poorly scripted attempt
to avoid international
scandal flopped badly.
On his return to Germany,
El-Masri promptly contacted an attorney
who reported his story
to the German police.
Public prosecutors initiated
a formal investigation
that would later result in arrest warrants
for 13 suspected CIA agents.
Other European investigations
surfaced every damning detail
of this ugly episode.
Macedonia was ordered by a European court
to pay compensation to El-Masri.
I won't offer a full anatomy
of the ACLU'S lawsuit that followed,
but you heard the thumbnail
version in my introduction.
Our suit against CIA officials
and contractors was dismissed
at the outset on the basis
of an affidavit submitted by, who else?
The CIA director, who
insisted that any litigation
of El-Masri's claims would
disclose state secrets
and gravely damage the nation's security.
As we would later argue
in an unsuccessful Supreme Court petition,
the El-Masri case now
stands for the proposition
that the government can engage in torture,
declare it a state secret,
and by virtue of that designation alone,
avoid any accountability for conduct
that has long been unlawful
in all circumstances.
What's so unsettling about the
secrecy claims in this case
is that El-Masri was not locked away
in a black site or Guantanamo.
He was free and available to testify,
and we were prepared
to litigate his claims
on public evidence.
In fact, he was sitting in the courtroom
in Richmond, Virginia when
Department of Justice argued
to the panel of appellate judges
that the entire subject matter
of his lawsuit was a state secret.
"I am not a state secret,"
El-Masri would later write
in an op-ed piece in
the Los Angeles Times.
As we'll discuss in more detail tomorrow,
the government prevails in these cases
by insisting on a distinction
between what the entire world knows
and what the government itself
is prepared to acknowledge.
In El-Masri's case, that
meant that his own testimony,
as well as all of the evidence
on earth by investigators,
all of the witnesses, lab
tests, public records,
even the judgements of foreign courts,
amounted to zero so
long as the CIA refused
to make a formal confession.
This gives the executive
branch complete control
over its own liability, even
for the most serious crimes.
There are a lot of words to
describe what's going on here,
but I would submit that secrecy
isn't a particularly apt one.
In June of 2016, more than five years
after the Court of Appeals
upheld the CIA suppression
of the Guantanamo transcripts,
the government quietly released
nearly complete versions
in response to a new ACLU FOIA lawsuit.
By that time, it was clear,
if there had been any lingering doubt,
that the Obama administration
had absolutely no interest
In pursuing further accountability
for the torture conspiracy.
The unredacted transcripts
make for harrowing reading.
"They pulled my hands up and cuffed them,"
recounts Majid Khan, "so I
won't be able to kneel down
and get rest for three days.
And when they took my clothes off,
and took me to the bathroom,
and dipped me in full ice,
an ice water tub, and
they hang me back again.
And this time, they
would throw cold water.
And every few hours, and right next to me,
they would turn on a fan.
Days passed like this,
three straight days."
"They shackle me
completely, even my head,"
recalls Abu Zubaydah.
"I can't do anything, like this.
And they put one cloth in my mouth,
and they put water, water, water.
Last point before I
die, they stand the bed,
and I tell him, 'If you
want to kill me, kill me.'
But it turned out that
brutality wasn't all
that the CIA had hoped to conceal.
Several prisoners testified
that they had made false confessions
and concocted fake terrorist
plots under torture
to appease their interrogators.
Abu Zubaydah requested numerous times
that the CIA produce for the
tribunal an email he had sent
to Islamic scholars after
9/11, asking them to clarify
whether killing innocent
civilians was permissible,
suggesting not only
that he wasn't involved,
but that he hadn't approved.
And he testified that a CIA
officer had acknowledged
that he wasn't even a member
of Al Qaeda and said to him,
"Sorry, we made a big mistake."
This is what the CIA had
fought so hard to conceal
under the banner of sources and methods.
The dirtiest secret was
that the torture prisons
were not just sadistic,
they were gratuitous.
The story has one more coda.
Even as civil and
criminal liability efforts
were being extinguished in the U.S.,
investigations proceeded overseas,
including in Poland where
Abu Zubaydah had been held
in a CIA black site in 2002 and 2003.
In 2010, Zubaydah's American lawyers
filed a criminal complaint in Poland
asking prosecutors there to investigate
whether any Polish nationals were involved
in his harsh treatment.
Polish prosecutors reached out
to the U.S. for information,
but were rebuffed on
national security grounds,
so they close their investigation.
But in 2015, the European
Court for Human Rights
took up the case and concluded
beyond a reasonable doubt,
based on voluminous evidence,
that Zubaydah had in fact
been held and tortured
at a CIA prison in Poland,
and that Poland had failed
to investigate the matter adequately.
Polish prosecutors again sought
information from the U.S.,
and they were again rebuffed.
The prosecutors then
told Zubaydah's lawyers,
they were free to submit any evidence
that might aid the investigation,
and Zubaydah's lawyers
served discovery requests
on two CIA psychologists
who had worked in the CIA's black sites.
The CIA moved to block these efforts,
invoking the state secrets privilege.
While it was true,
CIA director Mike Pompeo
conceded in a sworn affidavit,
that many details
of the CIA's enhanced
interrogation program
had now been declassified,
the CIA had never formally confirmed
that it had operated a prison in Poland.
This dispute led to what has to have been
one of the more bizarre
Supreme Court cases
in recent memory.
That the CIA had run a
black site in Poland,
again, was no secret.
After leaving office,
the President of Poland
at the time had publicly confirmed
that the CIA had set up the
prison with his knowledge.
In what has to be considered
the ultimate demonstration
of the Streisand Effect, the
Supreme Court heard arguments
and published 80 pages of opinions,
all devoted to the question
whether Poland's cooperation
with the CIA was a
legitimate state secret.
In the end, seven of the nine
justices said that it was.
As Ian Shapiro might say,
"Imagine the world is flat."
The court accepted the argument
that formal confirmation
of Poland's role might complicate
the CIA's future efforts
to enter into clandestine partnerships
with foreign intelligence services.
This isn't illogical.
It's just limitless.
It means that if the CIA makes sure
to involve a foreign partner,
it can always invoke state secrets
to foreclose accountability.
During the litigation,
the U.S. government proposed
an alternative way forward,
"Perhaps, instead of deposing
the CIA psychologists,
Abu Zubaydah could write
a document from his cell
in Guantanamo describing
his own recollections."
This caught my attention.
Was the government suggesting
as a resolution to this case,
exactly what it had fought
for years to prevent in mine?
Not quite.
The government reserved the right
to conduct a security review
of Zubaydah's manuscript.
As Justice Gorsuch wrote
in a surprising dissent,
"This was little more than
an offer to let Zubaydah say
whatever the government
chooses to allow him to say."
"There comes a point,"
Justice Gorsuch wrote,
"where we should not be ignorant as judges
of what we know to be true as citizens."
For the majority of the Supreme Court,
and for the U.S. legal system as a whole,
that time has not yet arrived.
Thank you for listening.
Hope to see some of you tomorrow,
and I would be glad to answer questions.
I should warn you the
answer to every question is,
"That's in tomorrow's lecture."
(audience laughing)
(Ben chuckling)
(audience applauding)
- [Ana] Thank you so much, Ben,
for, really, that fascinating
and thought-provoking talk.
We're going to use a microphone
because we are recording this lecture.
So if you want to pose a question,
please raise your hand and I'll
bring the microphone to you.
- [Audience Member 1] You
mentioned that the ACLU,
one of the things you try to
do, is build public backlash.
How did you go about doing
that, especially when support
for the terrorist may
not have been very high?
- So it's a good question.
So when you bring litigation
that you expect is not going
to succeed in a court of law,
you do so with the awareness
that the court of public opinion
might be the actual venue
that you're litigating in.
So the first thing that
you need to do, of course,
is explain to the
plaintiffs in these cases
that we're not likely to prevail,
so they don't get re-traumatized
through the process.
But part of it also is,
of strategic litigation,
is choosing plaintiffs, right?
We brought a case on
behalf of Khalid El-Masri
who was an innocent victim.
We didn't bring that
same case on behalf of,
of Khalid Sheik Mohammed,
who was subjected to
more brutal techniques
for precisely the reason you identify.
If the question before the public is,
"What rights should terrorists have?"
the answer will usually not be a good one.
But if you can present an error,
if you can show what happens
when due process is deprived,
when you do punishment
before trial, (chuckles)
then you can make people ask
a different question, right?
Are we willing to have a
system like this operating
in our name when we know
that there might be dozens
or hundreds of people who
were swept up inadvertently
because of the deprivation
of legal process?
I think there was, there was some success.
I don't want to be Pollyannaish here.
Obviously, my talk was the
opposite of that, right?
We completely failed in court.
There are some who have written books,
David Cole at Georgetown,
Jack Goldsmith at Harvard,
who argue that all of
this failed litigation,
in fact, succeeded in a way
in turning the public
against these activities,
eventually getting Congress activated,
making it politically impossible
for the CIA, in the future,
ever to agree to do
something like this again.
That may or may not be
right. We don't know.
It's two ways of looking at
the same body of evidence.
That was certainly the intent.
The intent was to use litigation
as a public demonstration
of what happens when you
abandon the rule of law.
- [Audience Member 2] So, I'm
sure you're gonna answer this
in tomorrow's lecture like you said.
(Ben chuckles)
But in our discussion of Poland,
the thing I was thinking of was,
in 2023, what does constitute
a legitimate state secret?
- In other words, what do I consider
to be a legitimate secret?
I mean, are you asking if I think
that there are legitimate state secrets?
- [Audience Member 2] Yeah.
- Okay. So I do, actually.
I think there are some who
would take the position
that there is no such thing
as a legitimate government secret.
I think the category isn't large.
Daniel Ellsberg recently gave an interview
to the New York Times, in
which he said that he thinks
maybe half of 1% of what's classified
should still be classified.
But examples of what
is properly classified,
certainly the identities of our agents
or informants overseas,
the disclosure of which
would lead to their deaths.
We shouldn't be publishing
troop movements in advance.
If a newspaper found out
about the bin Laden raid the night before,
it wouldn't be responsible
to publish the article before it happened.
Large troop movements can't
happen in secret anymore.
There's no, there's not
gonna be another Normandy.
But still that's legitimate.
And there may, certainly,
there may still be some secrets
related to nuclear proliferation.
Not many.
I think the real obstacle
to proliferation now
is material and not information.
Most people have the knowledge.
But I think those would be things
that are legitimate state secrets.
And I want to make another point,
and I will get into this more tomorrow.
Something might be a legitimate secret,
but we don't have to treat
that assertion as absolute.
In U.S. law, once a court accepts
the government's assertion
that something is secret,
say the U.S. relationship with Poland,
that's the end of the inquiry.
But what a court really
ought to do is say,
"What's at stake in this litigation?
What are the countervailing principles
that are at stake here?"
A torture victim's right
to have his case heard,
the system's need to have a resolution
of an important legal question,
and balance those interests.
Whereas we don't have any
proportionality analysis.
We don't have any balancing
in the U.S. legal system.
Once a secrecy claim is accepted
as legitimate, that's it.
It basically extinguishes the
case that we're talking about.
So that would be another way
that I would respond to that question.
- Yeah, so...
- Yeah, go ahead.
- [Audience Member 2] So,
I guess just to clarify,
you're saying that these are
not necessarily enumerated?
Like there's no list
of what constitutes a
legitimate state secret in 2023?
- That's, that's exactly
right, and in fact,
I'll say even more than that.
So, if the government
is invoking the state secrets privilege,
the category that the law uses
is national defense information.
The definition of that is so broad
that it refers to almost anything
relating to the foreign
policy of the United States.
If it's given its plain meaning,
it's clearly an unconstitutional law.
Courts generally equate it
with classified information.
But no, there's not anywhere you can find
an enumerated list of categories.
I mean, there are some
statutes that deal specifically
with say, signals intelligence,
and they would tell you with
a little bit more specificity.
But in general, the
state secrets privilege
is a judicially created doctrine.
There isn't even a statute
that establishes it.
The courts just said,
"We're going to apply this
common law evidentiary privilege
to give the government the ability
to shut down these cases."
- [Audience Member 3] So thank you for,
first, obviously, thank you
for coming to give this lecture
and the lecture tomorrow, but I think,
so given, so after listening
to this for around an hour now,
it's really depressing, (chuckles) right?
And so I guess for you,
like after decades of doing this work,
do you ever find yourself wondering
if there are other venues, other avenues,
to be addressing these, in particular,
these particular cases beyond
the court of public opinion?
Beyond the judicial system?
Especially, if we look at how
entrenched the judicial system
and the political
legislative bodies have been
over the past, a long time.
- Yeah, I mean, so there are
courts in other jurisdictions.
So we have helped present these cases
to courts in other
countries. (clears throat)
Paradoxically, there were,
a case that I didn't talk
tonight involved five citizens,
some citizens of the United Kingdom,
some citizens of Sweden,
who were victims of the
CIA's rendition program.
Their lawsuit was dismissed
in the United States
on state secrecy grounds, on the ground
that the CIA couldn't confirm
or deny its relationship
with foreign partners.
And the courts in those
other countries gave remedies
to the same people.
So they actually paid damages
for their minor roles in these renditions.
So, if you're talking
about a legal system,
there are courts in other places.
I also think part of this
is bearing witness, right?
General Pinochet in Chile did not expect
that he was gonna be arrested in London
and spend his twilight years
fighting against accusations
of what he had done decades earlier.
So, you know, I mentioned that Bush
and Cheney don't go to Europe right now.
So part of this is shrinking
the world for those people.
It's one form of accountability.
I do think public opinion is vital,
because it creates the climate
in which the next president will decide
whether or not to try something like this.
But I, you know, I was deliberate.
This was a record of failure, right?
Not my failure, the failure of
the system to give an answer
to some of these most
fundamental questions.
And the question I'm gonna
ask more pointedly tomorrow
is, "Why are we putting this
body of law on a pedestal
when it treats these vital
questions in these ways?"
- [Audience Member 3] Thank you.
- [Audience Member 4] So the fact
that the court isn't
answering these questions,
how much of that do you think is the fact
that they're sort of
delaying the requirement
that they come up with
a satisfactory answer
'cause they they can't think of one,
or because they already have an answer,
and they just don't want
to have to justify it?
- I, well.
The way that I've heard
judges talk about this,
and again, I'll get into this
tomorrow in some more detail,
I actually will,
is that when a senior leader
of the intelligence
community says to a judge,
"In my expert determination,
if you take these steps,
it's going to have X, Y, and Z effect
on our national security,"
two things are happening.
First of all, the judge
does doubt his own judgment,
doesn't necessarily want to be
the one to make that decision
in the face of that claim.
The second, what's been
communicated to that judge
is that if anything bad
happens, it's gonna be on you,
and all fingers are
gonna be pointed at you.
So it's a political comment as well.
And the theatricality of some of the ways
in which these secrecy claims are made
with an executive branch security officer
coming into the judge's chambers
with a briefcase handcuffed to his wrist
to deliver the classified
affidavit to the CIA Director.
There aren't a lot of circumstances
in which judges are
going to say, you know,
"That's nonsense."
There are some.
Where we just passed the 50th anniversary
of the Pentagon Papers case,
where the Nixon administration
almost persuaded a federal
judge to enjoin publication
on the basis of the government's assertion
that there would be grave
damage to national security.
The judge said later he
was expecting to enjoin it.
He kept saying to the
government, "Where's the evidence
that something bad is going to happen?"
And the government wasn't
able to produce anything.
More than a decade later,
the government lawyer who
was arguing this case said,
"Hey, I stood before the Supreme Court
and said the publication
of these documents
were going to lead to grave damage.
I've never seen a scintilla of evidence
of damage from their publication.
I've never even seen anybody claim
that there was damage
from their publication."
So again, my argument
is that the judges need
to be considering the
executive branch claims
in the context of that
history of deception.
But it's not easy.
The much easier thing
to do if you're a judge
is to kick it up to the next level, right?
There may be something
else going on as well,
if you're the Supreme Court here,
which is that it's a little odd
to have an agency like
the CIA in a democracy.
That is, we send agents
out into the world,
basically, to break the law.
And they don't wanna then be
dragged into a U.S. courtroom
to have what they did adjudicated
after they were sent
out to do these things.
And so we come up with
ways of describing that,
like secrecy, but it's not secrecy.
It's really just, you know, our trying
to put some scaffolding on
a decision that we've made
that these people are going
to operate outside the law,
and it wouldn't be fair
to subject them to it.
And again, I don't
think that's irrational.
I just think it's terrifying, right?
Because it has no limiting principle.
- [Audience Member 5] So for a class,
I was reading about Haitian refugees
who were kept in the
Guantanamo prison camp,
and I know there were some
recent sort of unconfirmed,
I think last year reports
that the Biden
administration was looking at
keeping migrants in
Guantanamo, in that area.
And I was just wondering
whether there are sort of legal avenues
to preventing sort of the
detaining of these types of,
whether it's refugees
or political prisoners.
Has the legal system sort
of evolved in any way
to prevent the next Guantanamo?
I'm not an expert on the
refugee side of things,
but you should know that,
actually, law students and faculty
here at Yale in the 1990s
brought successful challenges
on behalf of the Haitian refugees
who were held there then,
against the Clinton administration
and did create legal
pathways for those people
to be released from Guantanamo
and admitted into the United States.
And so that's quite a distinct
sort of category of law.
As far as the remaining, you know,
sort of so-called War on
Terror detainees at Guantanamo,
I think the best thing
that can be said about it
is that it's been a very, very long time
since anyone has been
brought to Guantanamo.
So I think the political class
and legal class have more or less decided
they're just going to
let this problem age out.
They're just going to let
the people who are there,
you know, at an incredible cost,
both in dollars and moral authority,
just grow old and die there,
the few that are left.
And, you know, part of
what's made it so difficult
to find homes, even for the ones
who the U.S. says should be released,
is that Congress passed a law saying
that no one who's been in
Guantanamo can ever be admitted
into the United States.
So we accepted zero.
And now we're telling all the
other countries in the world,
"If you don't like Guantanamo,
you've gotta take these people."
But we've taken none of them, so you know,
that has, obviously, made
it incredibly complicated
to get 800 people who
were held there released.
And then, and then, you know,
the last thing I will
say is that, of course,
we still are holding
the alleged perpetrators
of 9/11 at Guantanamo and
their trial hasn't started,
22 years after the attack.
- [Audience Member 6] Why
hasn't the trial started?
- Come tomorrow.
(audience laughing)
I'm not kidding.
- [Audience Member 6] Okay, I'll be here.
- Okay, yeah.
- [Staff Member] Can I have the mic?
- [Ana] Mm-hmm.
- [Staff Member] This side of the room.
- [Audience Member 7] So Ben, just,
I guess, a quick question.
Given that you mentioned Pinochet,
so that made me think about the processes
of truth and reconciliation
in Latin America
and the end of dictatorships
in the Southern con.
And part of that process
in some ways was a product
of also internal splits
within the military,
and younger cohorts being
tired of being accused
for the crimes of the elder cohorts.
I wonder if you see something like that
happening within the CIA?
Or, do you still see that as
a monolithic close agency?
- I don't know enough to answer that.
I mean, there were plenty of people
in the military who objected.
I mean, that's why we
know about Abu Ghraib.
That was a military whistleblower.
There were many uniformed
officers who came forward
and said, "We can't torture prisoners
because our people become prisoners."
So, and you had people who
were still in the military
who said that, and then you
had hundreds of officers
who had retired from the military who,
in brief after brief to the Supreme Court,
you know, made this argument.
So, there definitely were dissenters.
The only evidence we have from
the CIA side is, you know,
I mentioned there was a 2004
CIA Inspector General report.
The reason why there's an
Inspector General report
is that there were people, CIA people,
who are on site saying,
"This is crazy illegal,"
and reporting it to
their Inspector General.
So, but all, you know,
except for brief moments,
all of those internal
investigations stay under wraps.
They, you know, that 2004
report wasn't declassified
until 2010 and still redacted.
And you see how the CIA fought
against the release of the
Senate's investigation,
even hacking Senate investigators
to try to figure out
what they knew about the
CIA's torture program.
So, I don't know.
I think, again, I think what's.
I mean, anyone who has been
in a leadership position
at the CIA knows how legally
tenuous their position is
the minute that you let law inside.
As soon as you let external law inside,
so much of what they
do becomes problematic.
You know, the former CIA General Counsel,
his memoir was called "Company Man."
Right, and I think that
better describes the attitude
of people there.
- [Ana] Back to the other side.
- [Audience Member 8] Thank you.
So at a panel I watched
shortly after the Snowden revelations
with Chris Seghoian, actually,
and oh, can you hear me okay?
- I hear you fine.
- [Audience Member 8] Okay.
Yeah, and Mike Hayden.
(Ben chuckles)
Mike Hayden said,
he sort of acknowledged there
was a failure of transparency
and that there was a need for,
what he called "translucence", (chuckles)
(Ben chuckles)
which I take to be some
measured form of transparency.
And I later read Edgar's book
(Ben chuckles)
where he also sort of claimed
that there had been improvements
in transparency post Snowden.
- Tim Edgar's book?
- Exactly, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- "Beyond Snowden", yeah.
- Okay, yeah.
So my question to you is,
Do you feel the trajectory of, you know,
that there's been any
improvement in transparency,
and perhaps, you know,
(Ben sighs)
maybe comparing different parts
of the intelligence community,
including, you know, NSA,
and then, versus CIA or FBI.
- I think I would make a different point,
which is that almost without exception,
the important things that we learn
about secret government
activities come from leaks
and not through oversight.
So almost everything
important that we know
about government misconduct
in the last two decades
was accomplished because someone
on the inside shared
information with the press,
and the press published it.
Now, even when things get
declassified by the government,
they get declassified
because of public pressure
following leaks.
I really think breaking the law
is the engine for transparency.
You know, you saw during
the Clinton administration,
there was a kind of decent
push through a backlog
of ancient, you know,
classified information.
That's kind of not of interest to me.
That's not what I'm talking about.
I mean, interesting things come
out of that, and, you know,
the National Security Archive
does a good job there.
And there are, you know,
all kinds of people thinking
about this problem of
the billions of pages
of classified information from the past.
But in terms of, you know,
shining a light on activities
at a time that would give
the public an opportunity
to engage in democratic oversight,
very rarely is it a revelation
that comes out in, say, a public hearing
of the Senate Intelligence
Committee, right?
The really famous one
before Snowden was Clapper
sitting before Ron
Wyden, and Wyden saying,
"Is there any kind of
information that the NSA collects
on millions, or hundreds
of millions of Americans?"
And Clapper saying, you know,
"No sir, not wittingly."
Right, and, you know, we all say
that was Clapper lying to Congress,
but really it was Congress
not doing oversight.
Congress knew that it was a lie.
We were the only ones who
didn't know it was a lie, right?
So it's episodes like that,
that convinced someone like Snowden
there's actually not another way, right?
There isn't a way through the system.
Through the system is what
I just described to you,
tediously tonight for an hour, right?
- [Audience Member 9] Thanks. Thank you.
I'm interested in the role
that international criminal
justice might have to play here,
and the current position of the U.S. that,
well, the objection to
the ICC at all, basically,
which is now having
ramifications because, you know,
the U.S. won't share intelligence
and what Putin's doing,
et cetera, et cetera.
To what extent do you think
kind of a policy change there
would spill over and solve
any of these problems?
- Well, it might, but what possible basis
for optimism do we have here, right?
So, I completely understand
if you're in the U.S.
military right now saying,
"We can't share information with the ICC
because the ICC open investigation
of the U.S. in Afghanistan, right?
And what did the U.S. do in response?
We slapped sanctions on the
ICC prosecutors and said,
"You can't come to the United States
unless you drop your investigation
of the U.S. in Afghanistan."
So we can't say that these tribunals are,
investigatory bodies are
illegitimate as applied to us,
and then, you know, but what
a great place for Putin.
(chuckles) I mean, I do
think that's what they think.
But it actually is very difficult.
And look, I mean, my thesis here
is that impunity is the
organizing principle.
And so, you know, even the need
to provide a little bit more evidence
against, you know, someone like Putin
is not gonna be nearly strong
enough incentive for the U.S.
to subject its own leaders
to these kinds of tribunals, right.
In the back.
- [Audience Member 10]
It's a very brief question.
(Ben chuckles)
and if you'll answer it
tomorrow, then great.
But I wonder if you think
we would be better off
without all these organizations.
- Which organizations?
Oh, the three letter agencies?
- The CIA, the NSA, the FBI.
- I guess I'm not willing to say that.
I mean, the CIA is
probably the easiest case
to say probably.
The NSA with a properly constrained role
is probably a useful thing
for a government to have.
The FBI, certainly with a
properly constrained role.
The FBI should be doing more
to investigate financial
crime, for example.
I think having all of these agencies focus
the way they have on counter-terrorism,
and indiscriminately counterterrorism,
so from the sort of biggest
and most threatening iterations
of that to the smallest, and most trivial,
and even laughable, is
a huge, huge problem
and risks a repetition of what you saw
before the Church Committee
where the threat was communism.
The backdrop of that was
nuclear annihilation,
but the day-to-day FBI, CIA,
and NSA files were
left-wing college professors
and black student organizations.
And that's not happening
now in that same way.
But I think having these organizations
adopt a counterterrorism,
homeland security kind of mandate
in this really broad and non-specific way,
and like using everything as
threat fuel to justify budgets
and expansions is a major problem.
(audience chattering softly)
- [Ana] Are there any other questions
from this side of the room?
All right, so if there
are no more questions,
I would like to thank
everyone for attending today.
And I want to remind you
that we're gonna continue
this conversation tomorrow
at 4:00 PM, same room.
The title for tomorrow's talk
is "The Case Against
National Security" so...
- I should warn you that I wrote the title
before I wrote the lecture,
so it might have bitten
off more than I can chew.
(audience laughing)
(Ben laughing)
- [Ana] So I hope you
are as hooked as I am
on all of this talk, and I
will see you all tomorrow.
Thank you, Ben, so much for this.
- [Ben] Right.
(audience applauding)
(gentle bell chime music)